hello and welcome to episode 46 of
GameSpot after dark game sports official
video game podcast my name is Jake
Decker your host and joining me this
week is Lucy James hi John Luke psyche
hello and Kelly plaguey how are you all
doing another busy week in a another
busy week decade of busy weeks it truly
does feel like III is just getting
stretched out over weeks and weeks and
weeks and you know in my head at the
time I was like this will be better
it'll just be like everything will be
spread out and like it won't be as
stressful or condensed but I don't know
like this last weekend all those
conferences conferences that we were
doing it was it's like no release right
even even if like the individual day is
less busy there is no like oh well don't
worry like after you know this week
it'll all be over
cuz instead you go you have like your
weekend and then you're like I have
another week of this I have to do more
like the biggest first of all problem
yeah in the grand scheme of things I
definitely miss III too but it's I don't
know I'm fortunate but like I think
we're all fortunate was still working in
games and doing something kind of fun at
the end of the day totally yeah and it
has been fun like there's been a lot of
cool projects that we've been on a lot
of cool announcements um we can't talk
about yet but we will talk about soon
and some stuff that's already like out
there like there are a lot of great
games during like the gorilla collected
and the PC gaming show and all that kind
of stuff did you guys buy that itch IO
bundle I did Kali reminded me like an
hour before it expired and I was like
thank
will I play any of those games who knows
maybe I mean I went to the office
yesterday so they've changed it
completely we're not allowed in anymore
so because I'm doing a lot of streaming
they suggested that I pick up my PC from
the office and we Greg very kindly drove
John and I and I got it and I was like
well I've just bought over a thousand
games where do I begin downloading more
and then instead of doing that I watched
a video of a man repairing a painting so
oh I love those I'm gone a restoration
represent they're so good so good the
ones where he has to like stitch them
back together by taking off fill bits of
linen and using it as sutures oh my god
it's incredible art literally but but as
far as the game bundle goes I was really
interested in a short hike so I'm
excited that wasn't the bundle
I haven't played Overland night in the
woods was in that bundle which I would
recommend so there's a lot there's a lot
of good stuff I like started to look
through it and I was like if I keep
looking through this I'm gonna be here
all night
and it rings you isour cool it raised
8.1 million dollars oh my god
well they said serve as well cuz I was
looking through and they said yep we
know that these aren't organized very
well we're fixing it we're gonna put in
some back catalog which I appreciate
yeah and I like that the games don't
show up in your library until you've
like engaged with them so you don't have
this like 1,700 game oh that's good like
but um I guess we should say like that
bundle was to benefit justice basically
I think half the proceeds go to bail
funds and half was to the n-double-a-cp
or something I think so yeah and yeah
8.1 million dollars is like I it was
staggering we lost the best gaming deal
ever ever yeah yeah like I humblebundle
always has like those great deals but I
don't think
there's ever been I've seen anything
like this but yeah I'm looking forward
to going through those see what games to
play
but speaking of games to play Oh have
you all been playing or shows have you
been watching Lucy do you want to start
so I put in Avatar The Last Airbender
because canons know James Cameron and
it's not shaped me shape mate it's
actually fantastic and I love it and I'm
up to stop season three but I also
forgot that over the weekend I
downloaded horizon zero dawn because I
really liked the look of the West I love
so much about that game playing it away
talks to herself to an irritating degree
I want to turn that off now she don't
like G it's it's almost as if they don't
trust the player like you gave her ping
system with the focus so everything in
the environment is highlighted for you
she doesn't need to go like even that
opening bit where she's in that cave and
she's going I need to get out of here to
find rust and I'm like [ __ ] I know it's
the only thing I can do here you don't
need to repeat this to me and I and I
had forgotten that I had repressed that
anger at alloys over communication
because I think I had it with life is
strange as well max in life is strange
did it a lot but not to the extent that
a Lloyd is does it and so is is able
actually talking out louder she's just
talking in her head it sounds like it's
out loud okay they don't put any kind of
like reverb boring reverberation on it
to make it sound like it's in her head
but I love the movement in that game I
love hunting I love just running around
and I think the world design is
beautiful the creature design incredible
the bow play the lack of a better term
great just need her to be quiet but it's
I'm kind of basically looking for a
stopgap game before Last of Us and so
a game like I also haven't played the
DLC so a game like horizon I can just
dip in and I off that's what I've been
doing loved the look of the trailer
a forbidden West but Shh boy and and
also Jordan was talking about this in
slack earlier today like the decision to
not make a lloyd actually native is
weird considering all the native imagery
I can be in the game yeah I know there's
like story there's like story reasons
for that but it's like they got all the
way there except to just make her native
um which i think is a really good point
or just not use that native imagery like
they're right we're like you know if you
want to have her be the way she is for
the specific story reason like I get
that but then it's like why did you need
to make like I don't know it always like
come it's like that weird thing of like
society collapsed and they rebuilt and
they happen to use the exact same
imagery as these other cultures that and
it's like what no like that is a make
wouldn't they have like their own
original look like I you know I don't
know I always think that's weird that
like they just happen to also look a lot
like other specific cultures from long
ago I genuinely never even I didn't even
consider that honestly until I saw
Jordan break it up every and I was like
oh my god that's so right but you know
that's what I've been doing all rise in
an avatar I want to go back to harass
them I do want to do a deal see I really
liked horizon zero dawn I didn't finish
the DLC but I couldn't tell you what
happened in the story of that game but I
never missed it
all I remember is I thought the combat
was so much fun just because you were
like especially later in the game when
you're taking out these giant machines
where you had to switch to the right
arrow to take off the right part and
then you knock that part off and that
would change the battle so you'd switch
what you were using or like you could
shoot off a gun on a on a I don't know
metal t-rex or whatever and just that
back and forth and the way the
time slows when you start doing weapons
like I thought it all felt super good
like I had so much fun just taking down
monsters which is what I'm most excited
for
yeah the sequel and I'm excited to see
what they do is San Francisco cuz it I
saw someone on Twitter like pull a lot
of screenshots of like the Ferry
Building destroyed and whatnot and like
put those next to each other and it
looks super neat like I'm curious how
they're going to do that especially when
you consider I think they said the map
is supposed to be from like you talk to
San Francisco or something so like I
wonder what the scale is actually gonna
be in it so I think the original games
map was also like four different states
kind of compressed into one as well so
that doesn't necessarily mean it's gonna
be like crazy huge but yeah it's it was
gonna be much bigger though I want to
see what Salesforce towers like it's
like actually office is gonna be like I
think it's basically gonna be like what
it'll be it'll be it'll be similar to
what it'll be like when we actually are
allowed to go back yeah just nature's
reclaimed it if I get to pillage our our
office underwater that would be
incredible just yet a pile of Callias
plushies floating I'm so worried about
my tiny figurines what if they fell off
the desk and got vacuumed up I won't
know for months I'm so scared
I have many you have a lot a respectable
collection I shall Luke what have you
been up to uh well the game I played I
can't talk about this week unfortunately
but I I think it was like colleagues
like thinking so instead I actually
checked out a couple of demos that came
out for some games ultra kill and System
Shock they were part of the guerrilla
collective over the weekend last weekend
and they both heard two really
interesting so it's like oh they have
free demo so I'll check them out
I don't know if you're familiar with so
ultra kill it's it's another one of
those in the vein of like it's trying to
emulate like 90s shooters you know
you're dooms and your quakes there's
been a lot of those recently but what
makes this one really cool is that it
has like a Devil May Cry scoring system
and it's going for this like very ultra
fast you know it I'm trying to think of
like another games like speed equivalent
like imagine like the speed that you
could like get in like quake arena but
then you are expected to do like Devil
May Cry two combos and you can like
infinitely slide like an apex legends
and you're it's all about just like this
small rooms where you get in and then
these enemies come out and you're just
like doing these fast things like really
quick it's got a a like a hotline Miami
vibe where if you die it's just like up
nope you're just right back in it and
you just kind of keep going it's really
hard but it's it's really really like
frenetic and fun the abilities are like
insane and that they're all about just
trying to like combo it like trying to
be cool as possible so for example
there's a hand cannon and one of the
alternate abilities is you flick a coin
in the air and if you shoot the coin
it'll ricochet and immediately hit and
kill an enemy but you have to actually
physically aim at the coin and the coin
has its own physics so it like moves so
it's really really hard to actually like
nail that shot but if you do it you feel
like the like coolest person in the
world I cannot imagine yeah so I have to
make the coin a lot bigger so I'm so
strict is it's it's just really really
fun like I don't know I'm just
i I've tried a lot of those those kind
of games are trying like recapture the
spirit of like you know all those 90
shooters and there's been some pretty
good ones it's kind of been some like
hit or miss but I think I like this one
because it's more that it's just using
the aesthetic to be as visually simple
as possible so that you can just focus
on like how insane the action is and
then the demo takes a really weird turn
at the end because the whole thing is
your you're going through hell I think
it says something like hell is full and
you have to kill you know the demons are
here exactly
but you so the beginning it's like
there's like a prologue chapter that you
do which is like the first couple levels
and then you you do like the first level
of limbo and it like takes this complete
turn where it's like you know very sunny
and has like a very different vibe and
then there's suddenly no combat and you
do a bunch of witness style puzzles like
it's straight up has like the panels and
you're doing like the slighty block
puzzles and I just did that for like 10
minutes and it's like this escalating
like like actually like really good
witness style puzzles and I was like
what is going on in this game like I
thought you were just like killing
things and then right after that it just
goes right back to that and then the
devil ends and I was like okay
interesting how long did it take you to
finish the demo ah probably like 20
maybe 30 minutes okay that's a lot in 20
minutes yeah yeah yeah maybe like me
yeah maybe maybe just like 20 but it was
it was it's a substantial demo when it
went on longer than I thought and it
really gives you a good sense of the
game and now I'm just like I I'm so
curious if that games gonna like have
even weirder weirder [ __ ] in it because
I wasn't expecting there to be like
puzzle elements to it yeah so when we
were taking notes and that game trailer
came up mhm
it didn't say the name of the game at a
certain point but it had the website and
the website will make quake don't the
way he thought though those of us on
editorial who are taking notes thought
for a minute that it was called devil
make quake and we were like like I was
sitting there like can they do this
obviously it's not called [ __ ] yes I
mean I wish they did call it that
because that's an amazing name but I
think I think yeah they realize they
couldn't yet go ahead can I just do a
quick tangent about one of my favorite
Tumblr posts of all time which is okay
[Laughter]
we're just devil may happy and somebody
was like wouldn't it be devil may smile
and they're in GOP says critique my post
again and devil mate angry I that's good
I was gonna say it was was devil make
quake from like that section where that
guy came on who is like we hate money
here are games and like here no I don't
remember I know it was in the trailer
website it's the website you go to which
age which is just a link to their steam
page it just goes right to the steam
page for him because he had a bunch of
stuff like go to not fortnight calm for
this thing and stuff and it just felt
super weird and out of place they just
bought a bunch of really weird URL yeah
and like directed people to those and
then it ended with him being like we
hate money and then it just went back in
it no it was it was before the 11 bits
to do section okay was the 11 bits to do
that
yeah section all right well anyway you
also been playing a system shot he's a
big fan of the original and you've been
I mean I think one of your first videos
you made for GameSpot was about the
System Shock remake it was yeah so like
this the night time studios they're
doing a remake of the original system
shock and yeah they made a Kickstarter
back in 20 2016 and it came with its own
demo that was like a pre-alpha demos a
15 minute opening a slice of the game
and it was as Jake said it was one of
the first videos I ever did was
comparing it so I was real wild going
back and playing this new demo where
it's now like the entire first area of
the game it's the entire medical wing so
it's actually a really long demo and
could take you anywhere from like 30
minutes to an hour to play so you're
getting a really good substantial look
at the game and it's so good it's like
it's System Shock it's an immersive sim
it's like exactly what I love and like I
think they've just done such like a
fantastic job with it like it
looks really good it feels great they I
love the art style it uses this like a
you know it uh what's the word I'm
looking for like the the textures kind
of have like a pixelated look so it kind
of gives like a PlayStation 1 vibe but
it feels very modern it feels like a
good compromise to like this is clearly
like you know could only be made today
but also like play pays homage to the
aesthetic of that original game I not
100% but I think they still use all the
original voice actors or at least they
sound very similar like showed and
sounds the exact same it's it's just I
don't know like I don't know if I have
anything like to say that isn't like
been said a billion times about System
Shock but I think I'm just like really
excited because the original system
shock didn't kind of gets left behind
when people talk about all the shock
games like everyone talks about like you
know obviously Bioshock and those games
but like System Shock 2 is the big
System Shock game everyone talks about
but it's like System Shock 1 it's not
great to play now because the control
scheme was terrible I know if you've
ever you guys have ever seen that game
but like you open it up and it's like
it's got like a 50 billion different
like you Y menus and you can even use
the mouse to move originally like it was
an absolute mess of a game to play but
the actual game is really really good
like it still holds up like it still has
all of those like things that you love
about Bioshock like you know the writing
on the wall the you know your audio logs
of people dying horribly like finding
different stuff it even has like you
know those Metroidvania like elements
where you pick up an item and then you
can go back to a different area and that
game actually came out before Super
Metroid so it's like kind of it did
Metroidvania before Metroidvania existed
which is like really creating renamed
the genre for us exactly a system vania
roid
I'm looking forward to playing it
because like you're saying as someone
who has heard about mostly System Shock
2 and you know loves the original
BioShock it's like I played Bioshock 2
and even like pray hmm
you haven't played Bioshock 2 I haven't
played Bioshock - I got all nervous den
so I've yeah I've played Bioshock 1
multiple times and I've played bioshock
infinite multiple times and I've tried
to a couple of times but I never
actually finished it but I do own it on
ps4 PC there's probably more probably
360 - at some point so I really have no
excuse to have not played it but I
really do want at least you nervous den
you're still completely unspoiled on
bioshock smiles mad small-batch an
amazed small Bioshock 2 tangent I
actually did play that last weekend I
started it up because I was like for
whatever reason I was feeling an itch
and I was like I wanna play Bioshock 2
like I love that game I got and I got
all the way up to the end of not the
first level like the the level after
where you're going through like the
Andrew Ryan's like Museum I don't know
that it's and I played it a couple of
months ago so the the game crashed in
that game does not have auto saves and I
lost an hour of progress and I just went
all right well I guess I'm done playing
by shut - did you play the collection
yes done I was playing on PC but that's
the it was the remastered version the
collection no it's it's no is it like
the ps4 version oh I've heard it's not I
had not good
so I remember years ago when it first
came out it wouldn't let me download
BioShock Infinite because infinite was a
separate download it would let me do
bioshock's one and two but I couldn't
get infinite and then that fixed itself
or assumed it was patched and then a few
months ago I was playing Bioshock 2 cuz
on Jared Petty's podcast talking about
by Shore - and I had the exact same
thing happened to me with Minerva's Den
except I lost three yeah oh no I was
like well let's speedrun this section I
just no I just knocked it down too easy
and just like blasted through it but
yeah it's even worse on Bioshock though
because like I was meticulously picking
up every little audio log and I was
reading it and I was finding all this
ammo and I felt so good mm-hmm question
for you guys
what's the longest amount of progress
you've lost to something like that
mine's eight hours oh my god with what
it was just a game of Step five that I
was playing and I didn't say four eight
hours of my computer it was like what
that phaser I was just like we just stay
in my room displacive places and yeah I
definitely lost at least four hours
playing the original Mass Effect cuz I
had had no I think it was like the the
mission where do you find the rachni
Queen or something like I remember like
dying or something happened and then
like I loaded it back up and it was like
the very beginning of that planet and I
was like yeah I had a similar thing with
Mass Effect I think I played like five
hours I was exploring everything talking
to everyone I was so excited because
Mass Effect had just come out I've been
waiting for that game forever
and I was like you know I'm gonna just
go to a planet and I went to a planet
and a thresher ma showed up and killed
white plum party and I was like all
right I'll just reload yeah and then it
just like there's nothing to load and I
was like luckily you know I was in like
junior high or high school or whatever
and I had nothing but time so I started
writing up and did it again anyway but
still I remember being like are you
serious
Mass Effect god I remember the
auto-saves being really bad before boss
fights I remember when you rescue you
Liara and there are the there's the
krogan
like yeah guy and if you fail that boss
fight you well I say boss fight
if you fail that fight you have to do
the conversation over and over and over
again and unfortunately I got really
stuck on that fight and so I had to do
that over and over and over again and
it's it was 2007 man we should have been
but the most I lost was actually that
Bioshock Minerva's Den because I was
conditioned from a younger age because I
had a really shitty PC and I would play
The Sims a lot and if I didn't
meticulously save every ten or so
minutes it would probably crash
sometimes it would crash while saving
geez so I'm one of those people who
saves and then I'll just save again just
to be I used to be like that but I think
I've I just haven't played a game where
I've needed to do that in a while so
I've gone soft and then after that I
immediately was like okay where's the
quicksave key for the bioshock the best
game on console at least for saving was
Dishonored 2 is Dishonored 2 it had
quick save and load in the pause menu on
the triggers perfect because I was save
scumming my way through that game so
chaos theory had that too I remember
that being a game changer for the
Splinter Cell series because like before
there were just checkpoints and you know
if you're playing that very slowly and
meticulously and you die it's like now I
got to go back like four or five
encounters but with chaos theory they
added that quick save and I think that's
effects 3 they added one like on console
worried if you like held the back button
it was like oh say because I think cuz
they knew because that was like such an
issue that series they were like we'll
add the thing for console people I've
always been sorry I was just gonna say I
had like 80 hours in Pokemon firered
and I dropped my Gameboy Advance SP and
it landed on the cart and it shut
everything down and I was like I hope
this save turned it on you know you get
the whole new game things show up and I
was like I was so mad when you lost it
all yeah it's all gone why
that's the worst well cuz I didn't think
about it until now I was much younger
and also like God I didn't think about
like me losing save I don't know yeah
yeah it was user error right like
nothing shut down I just was a dumb kid
and dropped it on the ground
geez I stress I was just gonna say I've
always been really neurotic about saving
and I'm the kind of person that I'm like
I saved my game and then I'm like did I
save and then I save again the SIV
example had autosave but for some reason
didn't it didn't autosave what I needed
maybe that was part of the crash maybe
but also I had a Mount Fuji as Japan
working in Premiere Pro I don't do so
much editing anymore but when I first
got premier the autosave is like
automatically set of 15 minutes I think
it was I think now it isn't now I switch
it to like 30 second however low it'll
go I did I change it to 5 minutes every
time I start fresh cuz 5 minutes is like
I can do that yeah you want to talk
about a real devastating save loss oh
wow premier projects yes work yeah work
losing and the whole days Eddy has
happened to me and it's just you you
just you just go home you just go home
yeah it'll be like 4:30 on a Friday and
I'll be almost done with the review and
then it'll crash and for some reason I
won't have any backup saves it'll be
like well I'm just gonna throw a bunch
of random clips into this review I'm
sorry
oh thanks well that hasn't happened it
hasn't been a very long time and
honestly I was pretty new at GameSpot so
I probably just stayed till like
midnight making sure it was ok which I
don't recommend
don't stay work till midnight unless you
have to no anyway moving on I guess I'll
talk about one thing I've been playing
and then we can talk a little about
Pokemon cally mm-hmm
and then we're not gonna talk too much
about Last of Us because we talked about
it a lot last week jean-luc and Lucy
haven't played it and we're also gonna
have a spoiler chat go up this weekend
and you can read both my spoiler free
review
my review with some spoilers correct
there's a ton of places that we're gonna
be talking about Last of Us order that
we've already talked about last of us so
you can check that out now but anyway
the other game I've been playing other
than Pokemon right now is persona 4
golden on PC I don't have a whole lot
and it's still very good
I just finished you Kiko's palace so I'm
still pretty early let's go
but I'm having a lot of fun with the
difficulty settings because I've played
like 70% of that game on Vita and I
never finished it so I like made it as
easy as possible so I could burn through
all the palaces as fast as I could and I
did you Keiko's Palace in one day which
isn't super impressive since it's the
first palace but I'll take what I can
get I'm like hovering on the edge of
playing it through again but it took me
two years because I had an ollie commute
and I had my veto and that's how I
played persona 4 but also I wonder if
persona 5 and all the quality of life
improvements in 5 maybe have ruined me
from going back I don't think so at
least something's for me I cuz I played
it I play it last year for the first
time with my girlfriend which is kind of
a bummer because I'm like oh man could
have played this for Asian bad sky but I
I think for one I think those games were
just mechanically different enough that
like it's more that like I don't know
like the quality life changes don't feel
as it doesn't feel as dramatic I would
say from like say like 3 to 4 which felt
like pretty dramatic also I think that
the game's character isn't story are
just like holed up on their own so much
like yeah I don't know like I I think
each persona game has its own strengths
that make them worth going back to
accept the no you can't control your
party members directly in 3 and that is
terrible no not the original version of
3 the PSP version you can but it also
loses at oh I get into it but all I'm
saying is there's no
version of persona 3 and they need to
make it and that is why Alice should
remake persona 3 if you're listening
atlas give me persona 3 remastered well
we'll forward this podcast to them
please man but is it just Atlas at
gmail.com right yeah yeah I think so
cool JP yeah sorry do whoever has that
email address Atlas and gmail don't go
but anyway yeah like I said I don't have
a whole lot to say about persona for
gold and other than that I am excited to
be playing it again and I'm happy it's
on PC I hope this means that we'll see
some Atlas games on PC maybe even switch
like the crazy thing about playing it on
PC is that as I was playing it on PC
this is really dumb but as I was playing
on PC I was like man I wish this is on
switch I'd rather nobody there's
something real weird about having like a
graphic settings and a persona game like
mouse and keyboard controls yeah they're
just like weird since I did not do maths
and keyboard immediately control but
even on an Xbox controller it feels kind
of weird
a nice little tiny touch this is like so
small but I like when games do this it
actually changes the button icons
depending which controller you point
like that a lot - I like that small
little thing but I like when games do
that so the big thing which came out
today well it came out Wednesday if you
listen to this now it's Friday but Kelly
and I have been playing some of the Isle
of armor DLC I played about an hour
today I'm not sure much you got to play
Kali not much but I I did a like a
preview session last week where I saw
the First's 40-ish minutes so we've
probably played flash seeing the same
amount of the game I'd say so
um I yeah I don't all right now I'm very
excited and enjoying it just because
there are so many more Pokemon - catch
and like at the end of the day that's
what I wanted to do the most was just
catch more Pokemon and have more Pokemon
to build teams with I can't really speak
on the story
it's like I said I've only played an
hour but it seems very Pokemon II like I
don't it's not that deep but it doesn't
really need to be yeah I mean it's it's
cute you kind of get roped in in a very
anime protagonist style into joining
this dojo and it's run by a couple named
honey and mustard and mustard is he kind
of his like the king bumi of Pokemon
planet said that reference from Avatar
he's he's like quirky and wacky but he
has a point to what he's doing so he has
everybody at the dojo kind of doing
these like they seem like otherwise
menial tasks but it's one of those like
oh I'm a dojo master and I know what you
need to get better or whatever kind of
vibe and so you have to like catch these
like slowpoke he's trained to be
especially fast which is really silly
and also like I think really clever
because you can train Pokemon to be
faster or have better attack or better
defense like you can customize the
Pokemon that way within the game so it's
kind of cool that it's like these are
the fastest slowpoke you'll ever see and
they even have salic berry which when
it's one of those it's a it's called a
pinch berry it's activated when the
pokemons low on health and the salic
berry increases speed when the Pokemon
eats it so they're like just fully speed
SPECT slowpoke which you would never do
ever that doesn't make any sense but
like it's cute
it kind of just drives home like this is
you can you can make a Pokemon like the
fastest it could be so I thought that
was collaborate to go hunting for
mushrooms and stuff for him he gives you
he and honey give you either a paw
squirtle or a Bulbasaur that can
eventually Giganta max when you fully
evolved them so that's kind of like the
basic like that's the starting point of
it and and the level the leveling also
scales to where you're at when you start
the DLC so you can start it basically
you only have to play the main game for
about an hour once you hit the wild area
in
main game you can then travel to the
Isle of armor and the pokemons levels
will be appropriate to your level the
same way they are in the wild area so
that's pretty cool
and the Pokemon two aren't locked behind
the DLC anybody can get those Pokemon in
their pokedex now there was an update
released alongside the the DLC so yeah
it's it's exciting I poke one is really
good DLC so that's just exciting it's
kind of uncharted territory yeah I mean
I've been having fun with it I I really
like the wild area this new wild area
because it seems like they've learned a
lot from the original wild area and this
one's already so much more interesting
like there are caves there forests like
coastlines the the diversity is is
there's way more diversity and it's a
lot more interesting to explore so far
in my opinion in like I don't know it's
just exciting to walk around and see old
Pokemon again that weren't in the game
like I caught a rock rough which I've
already evolved into a liking rock I
caught a UH I caught a cadet I caught an
abra which is one of my favorite Pokemon
originally I'm still trying to find
Shinx because I know she's here but I
haven't found jinx yet but yeah as of
now I mean it's just more Pokemon and so
far that seems like a pretty good thing
I will say the the slowpokes in the wild
area when you have to get them they're
like going so fast there's a dust trail
behind them and like the sound they make
is really funny like you almost have to
like you can't chase them you just have
to figure out their path and cut them
off it's really silly um I was gonna say
the other thing that's really cool about
it is the music it's like oh yeah you
told me this beforehand so the music
really caught my attention because it is
a remix of the look that the stereo I
don't know monix no joke for British
people is it's like everybody was kung
fu fighting tuned goodbye
like that tune who sings on everybody
but and so at first I was kind of like
Oh interesting choice but the halls of
definite ease people made this game and
wrote the music but the remix is like
such a banger it's like laughs it was
just like let's go I'm ready to fight
okay so it's kind of silly but it's I
enjoyed it a lot
another cool thing too I don't know if
you saw that far but maybe they had
already said it but you can turn any
Pokemon into Giganta max now oh there's
kind of cool it's super cool there's a
this is just this is the thing with
sword and shield is they give you so
much to turn any old Pokemon into a
Pokemon you want to use like if you have
a shiny Charizard now you can make that
a shiny gigantic max Charizard like
that's so freakin cool it's it's max
soup is the like the food item that you
that does it and that's one of the
things when you're looking for the
mushrooms for mustard for I don't notice
it sensei mustard I don't know he is
like oh I need them to make max soup so
that's part of it
you get you get new clothing options new
hair stylist oh now we're talking baby
like like a cute ass bun like there's
there's like this like swoopy fade thing
going on like there's a lot of cool
stuff that's all I care about and this
is I mean I I'm finishing up the last
bus review the the spoiler version of
that so I haven't had time yet today to
actually play so there's a lot that I'm
still going to delve into and I am doing
a review of aya little armor I'm gonna
do that as quickly as is physically
possible for me to do ira mentally
possible probably is more accurate but
yeah I it's it's I mean I'm still I play
I play in one crossing every day I'm
fully obsessed animal crossing so it's a
little bit like I will never put down my
switch ever again because no I'm playing
one else
but um it's it's kind of nice I I kind
of needed this after the Last of Us so I
was gonna say in terms of tonal whiplash
I don't think you could get anything
more opposite mm-hmm yeah and and it's
funny because the comments I always get
comments they're like just go back to
playing Pokemon you don't like violence
you stupid girl and I'm like well I mean
Pokemon is about making animals to fight
each other but but um you know it's it's
colorful and friendly about it that's
nice
which if you think about it it's
actually even more disturbing yeah I'm
gonna go call Peter right now well
anyway let's move on to topics for this
week the big thing that happened last
week that we tried to guess was the ps5
reveal event I don't remember what I
guess last week other than bet we'd see
horizon - I was right mm-hmm
I've been very very surprised if horizon
2 hadn't yeah yeah I've been there I
guess anything so I can't be wrong I
don't remember what anyone else guessed
and they're not here to tell me what
they guess so I guess so we were all
correct but anyway um speaking of the
ps5 reveal event why don't we just say
what our favorite announcement was and
we can gonna kick off conversation from
there cuz there was a lot of cool stuff
I would say John Luke gonna start I love
the dumb look of the PS 5 I think it
looks so stupid and I am so excited to
have it on my shelf I was on the pre and
post-show and afterwards I was clearly
in a state of hype and it was talking
about like damn she thick my boyfriend
texted me after and it was like do you
want to have sex with that PlayStation 5
like you are describing it in a weird
way and I was like I don't know I was
just excited she should go caves man how
do you bother me but I like how the the
one with the disk drive is a little
sited - well it's just you she got
Allari it's weird like the one on the
disk side is lopsided when it's standing
up but when you put it down it kind of
works when you put the one with a out
the disc drive down it then has this my
mic has this gap at the bottom that
looks really weird so it's like it
doesn't work perfectly either way like
it's such a mess
I'm I love it I love it with all my
heart like I am I'm such a fan of like
weird-ass consoles it looks huge I don't
know where I'm gonna put it I'm just
excited for it someone's made an AR
thing you can do and you can see because
if people have figured out based on disk
drive size how big the console would be
and they've made an AR that you can
place the PS 5 in your house and I'm
like I'm just lucky that I have an open
top entertainment unit cuz if I was
trying to fit it into some kind of
pre-made shelving unit it will not it
will not fit my shelf so I do need to
figure something out I a symmetry
bothers me a lot and I don't know if
I'll be able to handle the PS 5 in its
current form I don't I can't I can't I
can't you can get the no disk drive one
that's more symmetrical that is
symmetrical right that's symmetrical I
mean but then it's like then you won't
have a disk drive which you might
genuine a need for your job yes it sends
you dis code exactly so yeah I don't
know I wasn't crazy about it
I also I wasn't able to watch the
presentation because I was working on
the spoiler-free Last of Us review so I
I've really only I've seen bug snacks
and I've seen horizon and everyone
obsessed with bug snacks this song man
in our house like you'll just hear
through the wall sometimes Jenna Greg
going bug snacks I was hoping that they
would hear me do it yeah all the time
there's been a lot of good memes of
people putting the bugs next song of
movie trailers someone put it over the
Joker one which I did
pretty funny but I liked someone was a
game ran yesterday wrote an article it
was like what if bug snacks is secretly
like a horror game where you eat
sentient so always expecting the trailer
to take a dark turn cuz it was like so
happy and it's like yeah and these these
bugs and that bug looks like a taco and
I'm like it's gonna get weird like I
mean like weirder and so I don't know I
I entertain that theory are you like are
you picturing like Seth Rogen sausage
party is horribly offensive and bad but
like you know like it takes like a weird
horror turn like like when they like you
know the game starts to come out and
then the ESRB is like yeah this game is
rated and everyone's like why mature
themes Kali you said you didn't see the
presentation as a whole but was there
anything that any trailers or something
that may have stood out or news i I just
really don't like the PS 5 alright how
about you Lucy uh well I know it was
already announced but death loop seeing
more of that like anything arcane
touches I will be all over
I genuinely was it was fun being because
we were kind of on I was on stream with
Michael and Tom and you know the
reactions to Miles Morales even though
the messaging after that was a bit all
over the place and time can I can easily
say that that Demon Souls reveal was the
highlight of history oh well I think it
was a really good mix of triple-a there
was there was some usual suspects that I
felt were missing like I fully expected
card especially because they just
updated season four of warzone that day
and people were saying oh there's clues
being left and I fully expected card but
it's fun like was a game that look like
Pixar character Kenner
yeah kena yeah that looks cute that
looks pretty looks like a mix of breath
in the wild Pixar and I don't know like
magic stuff in there too maybe bit of
horizon zero dawn not to be productive
and just haven't really seen much else
of the game but it was cool like I think
that's Sony's best conference since e3
2015 easily which was the Final Fantasy
7 Last Guardian yeah oh and resi 8 oh
yes
oh yeah that's maybe the game and I'm
the most excited for out of out of that
whole thing that game looked incredible
yeah I mean Resident Evil 8 was
definitely mine but I would probably say
demon souls as well if not more just
because part of it is because I've been
replaying the souls games the souls
boring games recently and I've never
played Demon Souls I had no plan to play
demon souls because I wasn't gonna track
down a ps3 and yeah I just figured I'd
never play that game unless there was a
remake so I'm very excited that there's
a remake and it looks great based on the
trailer I'm super excited to see more
I'm especially curious to see another
studio tackle a from software game
because I feel like a firm salt from
software games have such a distinct feel
to them and like the way they play so
I'm curious to see if like I don't know
I guess like how much blue point can
match that or maybe try something kind
of different but also it can't be too
different because then it wouldn't I
don't know that would be a terrifying
game to remake if if they're not yeah
from software but regardless I'm so
excited I thought it looked it looked
beautiful and it was definitely like
even though I think we all knew it was
gonna happen it was still exciting to
see that yeah I'm so curious if they're
gonna add or change anything cuz I think
they've said that it's mm-hmm a more
dramatic we it's not gonna be quite like
shadow where it was like very faithful
like I think they said they're gonna
like change some things or add some
stuff I know people are speculating like
there's a whole area of that game that
got cut where you go to this like snow
like area that was like home to like the
Giants and
there's actually a good Vaati video
video where he like talked about that
all right I forgot about that some
people were like speculating like what
if they put that back in the game I
don't necessarily get my hopes up too
much that they're gonna do something as
dramatic as that but I'm really curious
if they're actually going to like take
the opportunity to add or change
anything because yeah there are shadows
because there was a there's a lot of
when we into them for audio logs last
year there's a lot of stuff in shadow
you know a way to Sun originally had
ideas for that I think it was 24 colossi
instead of 48 at one point yeah
say they left some stuff in the game and
there's like the garden at the top that
you can get to if you platform up in a
very specific way even though there's
nothing there like there's all these
rumors about the 17th Colossus and you
know they didn't put any of that in the
only thing they put in was like that new
collectible sword right and and yeah and
the sword which was a reference to one
of the community members like no matter
doesn't it mm-hmm
so I mean in terms of like changing
things obviously they changed the
control scheme to modernize it I wonder
how like he said I just wonder how much
they would I wonder what Fromm's
involvement was from the sounds of it
right
the original shadow team wasn't that
involved in the remake asides from
handing over things
I wonder if from has any oversight and I
wonder if they are gonna put cut stuff
back in yeah I mean really cool that
would be awesome and to like unlike
Shadow of the Colossus there have been
multiple souls games after demon souls
that have refined and added and changed
and and then all this stuff so like I
imagine it couldn't just be like they'd
have to do something with the gameplay
they couldn't just leave it as is
otherwise it would still probably feel
dated like an easy example is like the
role in that game is much more limited
in terms of like how many directions you
can roll in compared to later games so
they could add like you know they can
make the roll more dynamic that's like a
really small thing that like you would
hope they would add just to make it like
feel
more modern but there was a really cool
thing when we were talking with them
that so the Blue Point engine is cool
and it like it basically runs their
version of the game in the original
version of the game at the same time and
there was a really cool thing that they
were saying that like some of the coding
in the original version of Shadow was so
cool that they just like kept it so I
think the on Wanda's poncho he has these
little fringe things around his belt and
that's the original coding from ps2
shadow that they used in the ps4 vision
I saw I saw Bochy speculating because
cuz they I guess at one point there was
a description I forget if it was like in
the trailer like the YouTube trailer
description like they took it out but it
said like it mentioned a thing called
fractured mode which is not a thing from
the original game at all and the fact
that they took it out I don't know if
that means like that's they didn't want
to talk about it or if like that's not
correct like who knows like I don't want
to like you know say that's definitely a
thing but he was kind of speculating
like well what could that even be and
one of the things he was saying like was
what if they let you actually switch
between like the og art style like in
the new one like in the vein of the halo
yeah because you know some people have
been kind of complaining about how like
the new art style loses some of the
atmosphere and I could certainly
understand some of those arguments it
was certain areas so that would be cool
I don't know if they would actually do
that that sounds like a lot of work and
I don't know if their engine is capable
of going that far with it but that'd be
neat well anyway the next thing we have
here is pokemon snap which was announced
today new pokemon snap right did you
guys play pokemon snap at all the
original I did Oh
wearing a god damn Pikachu [ __ ] the real
question is did you guys have a
blockbuster that had that kiosk you
could go and print out your pokemon snap
stuff too I don't think so oh so like
you could go to the blockbuster and they
had like a machine
and you could like bring your memory
card and it would like print out your
photos for you what yeah yeah that's
what I get for going to Hollywood video
and because I never owned an n64 I I
played the game my friend south but I
remember like going to the Blockbuster
and seeing and be like oh my god I wish
I had this game because I would totally
do that so I never actually got to print
about myself unfortunately but I did see
that machine and I was like man I wish I
could do that that's awesome I I think I
only speaking of blockbuster and stuff I
don't think I ever owned Pokemon snipper
I think they must have rented it I we
rented most of our games back then hmm
back back and by then we had to walk 13
miles to the blockbuster Hollywood video
actually the Hollywood video in my case
which was actually extremely close to my
house it would have taken about two
minutes for me to go there yeah so I my
memory of it is not very strong I don't
have the same attachment to it that a
lot of people do I I played a lot of
Pokemon spin-off games on the Gamecube
that's where like there were some some
real interesting ones like Pokemon
Channel but um I I didn't do too many I
had Pokemon Stadium and stuff but
pokemon snap eight I don't think we
owned or if we did I don't remember it
but um it the it is actually called new
Pokemon snap and it looks really good
I'm excited so it's not a brand new day
game or is it just you it is a new game
and it is inspired by the n64 classic
according to the Pokemon company
interesting I'm kind of with you Kelly
and then like I remember playing it as a
kid but I don't think I ever owned it so
I didn't really have much of an
attachment to it
I do remember for my Nintendo 64 getting
Hey You Pikachu
oh yeah kind of a mess yeah oh god yeah
but because like you were supposed to
talk to Pikachu but I had nothing worked
it was I don't know is just a little kid
screaming into a headset and nothing
actually just like on my games today you
know
I think the coolest thing about Pokemon
snap is how it encouraged that sort of
like rumor a lot of like the rumor like
playground remember stuff where because
it would be very much like yeah like no
you've got to throw your your Apple like
right into that you know like volcano
and then it like explodes and like
that's where like you know magmar comes
out of and like like it had that kind of
like oh I got to go home and try this
like to see if I can find that so like
I'm really excited to like play the game
and like see what kind of like weird and
then to of like secrets they have like
how you can find examples of Pokemon I
saw someone posted a gift I don't know
if it's real but it was from it looked
like it was from Pokemon snap of like
going next to a volcano and I think
there's like a term million like walking
around next to it and someone threw an
apple at him and he fell into the
volcano like if this is real this is
hilarious I should look into that but I
thought that was pretty funny but yeah
I'm excited just to see what a Pokemon
snap game is gonna look like in 2020
like that alone has me interested I
definitely wasn't one of those people
asking for pokemon snap during every
Pokemon event like many people usually
do so I'm very excited that those people
finally get a sequel to pokemon snap or
a new pokemon stamp called new pokemon
snap they new pokemon snap one more time
my day new pokemon snap thank you anyway
Jake that think that that was totally
legit you do you have to that was yeah
you can be pushing this you have to push
him in and then he evolved into
Charmeleon and then you push him in
again and evolves into Charizard man
that poor child Mandor damn okay yeah I
I don't know I there is going to be
another announcement next week which is
interesting I don't know why they saved
it I'm like it like I am one of the
people that asks for Johto remakes every
announcement so I'm like when are we
getting a Johto remake even though we've
already had a joto remake and Gen 4
hasn't had a remake with Gen 4 is the
worst Jensen nobody cares I forget who
it was but there was somebody on Twitter
a lot of people cared Asami who is
saying that like I guess all the poking
plushies behind I forget who they're all
Geraldo and everyone's like those are
all Jota Pokemon so the thing about that
is there was a very recent a relatively
recent line of Johto plushies so last
year the Pokemon company had like this
whole gen 1 plushie line were they'd a
plush for every single Pokemon from the
original 151 and they're doing that
again with Gen 2 so it could just be
related to that but there was like a
let's go Evie box and it was an Eevee
and SP on an Umbreon so I'm gonna go
full conspiracy theorist I'm like yeah I
yes and they definitely filmed
whatever happened next week on the same
day like for sure yeah I yeah I there's
a lot of Johto Pokemon like it's not
even just that one line there's like a
line of it's a lot of legendaries you
see like the legendary dogs and stuff
but there's also in the top right or the
top-left corner there's a bunch of Johto
Pokemon so I was like you know what I'm
gonna join this chorus of people that
are like it's a hint do you think if
they made let's go Pikachu let's go Evie
- that took place in Johto do you think
you'd be able to go back to Kanto or do
you think they'd cut that because that's
a question that I was I mean we're so
far out here now but like - Johto
like I think you have to have that
that's what makes Genji so special I do
- I mean I agree it's my favorite my
favorite part of that game originally
was finding out that I could go back to
canto and do all that kind of stuff but
I wonder if like maybe the cuz Pokemon
let's go ahead like a slightly different
story and like some of the gameplay was
a little bit different and I'm curious
if maybe but they'll do that and that
concerns me
the further we get from let's go the
less I think that it would be a let's go
style remake just because I think that
while let's go was pretty successful I
think it was very much intended for the
Pokemon go audience to kind of jump on
the Pokemon game train force which being
the first Pokemon RPG on switch so
that's why I don't think it would
necessarily be in the let's ghost
I mean I'm I'm like one of those people
I want the one Tamriel I'm Pokemon I
want to be a food every region oh I am I
am too too invested in that sort of
thing but if I had if like I'm calling
it now this is my prediction I would say
it's not a let's go style it is its own
kind of reap like if it is a joto remake
it would be its own kind of juda remake
specifically utilizing what the switch
can do Johto being such a popular
generation that would be my my biggest
wish that's my biggest wish to get ya
really know that's what I think about
like how they could connect them all
where it's like okay well you could take
the train from you know like this region
to this region and then you can take
like the boat over there to that like I
I also think about that a lot about how
you could connect all those mats I
thought about it with with freaking
sword and shield because there's a train
line yes and it's in Britain and there's
gate I'm messing up my hair so agitated
and there's there's games set in France
you know that where's the Chunnel it's
right there we could just go over there
I want to take the channel the Polka
Channel I mean that channeled y ou
ignore me sorry mi I'm spacing out I've
had a weird day I mean we need like that
sure when you said channel I was like do
you mean the Channel Tunnel is that a
thing that people call it I just never
knew that because I'm thinking of the
actual Channel Tunnel in the UK to
friend us ignore me that wait I thought
is it not called the channel the tunnel
that connects the UK to France
yeah I never heard literally over 10
years I was called the shuttle NASA
anyone say well we got a name for this
episode I like I've thought since the
high school that it was called that I
honestly never had anyone ever say that
I I think I was being bullied dude you
can't do it believe it's just like when
we told Mike Mahadi that the channel
tunnel also called the never do as the
tunnel yeah sure oh my god mom refers to
it as the channel Americans are too
stupid to remember two words Lucy or
maybe maybe Lucy is just she's no longer
British anymore that's true maybe it's
just no longer channels I org dot uk'
that's the website I genuinely never
heard anyone say channel maybe it's one
of those things where like most locals
don't actually say that we would say you
get the Eurostar or you'd go through the
channel tunnel so to go to Paris but
like Channel Tunnel is is more like you
drive or you like you get on and then
you're taken through and then Eurostar
is the actual train see in America we
also don't have trains like that that's
true so where's our chugging thing about
anything where's Otto where's our anyway
let's move on let's keep going here we
got some listener questions if you've
got any questions for us you can email
us at after dark podcast at GameSpot
calm or you can join our discord server
to do that just message any one of us on
Twitter or email us and we will get you
right in there as soon as possible first
questions from Adam on discord Lucy do
you want to take this first one I was
listening to the Jet Set Radio future
soundtrack this morning and it made me
wonder if a new game in an all but
abandoned franchise was announced what
franchise would that need to be for you
to buy day one without a second thought
hmm Splinter Cell I just wanted to say
Splinter Cell on this podcast so I
included this is that all but abandoned
though they've you know they put Sam
Fisher and goes to reach our reimagined
it it's a band-aid yeah my man's shown
up and goes through kinda like this is
an easy one but anything from Konami
like you know Castlevania yeah I'd get I
guess it depends though I don't know
maybe I don't know if it'd be an instant
buy though because I don't know if I
would trust Konami um I don't know cuz I
it's kind of happening for my one I
would love a new Bioshock they have said
that they're making one what it's what's
a dead Frenchman I mean I originally my
go-to would be Psychonauts 2 and a new
Beyond Good and Evil and and they
announced the Psychonauts to a couple
years ago CH I'm very excited for and
they announced Beyond Good and Evil 2
yes nicely I'll have to say that's
that's a that's my answer is my till
Republic that's a good thing if they
made a new knight seller Republic
instantly that's 100% my answer does
Mass Effect count is that abandon I was
thinking there's only been four years
I think what's what's limitations on a
French was being banded like ten years
that's an age in game time I would yeah
a generation yeah yeah yeah hasn't been
a whole new game and in a generation
well then Splinter Cell works but it
does because the last one was on 360 Oh
so does kotor count them because we have
the old republic hmm I used to say
counts because old republic they don't
they haven't supported I mean I think
it's still up but they haven't like
added content to it for a while yeah I
just like mmo's intimidate me so much
that I'm good I just couldn't I was like
and it's just it's not the same I put I
tried playing it and it's like hmm it's
not it's not the same okay so kotor
cancel is what we this yes I have a [ __ ]
I have another shitty answer Elder
Scrolls 6 that's I mean they are working
on it yeah it's been almost a decade
though every time that clock I know yeah
yeah I guess I'm just fortunate enough
that a lot of the franchise's I care
about have continued I mean I guess like
I played a lot of tycoon games and they
have kind of died off but there's like
planet coaster and planet zoo or like
you know I would love for there to be a
good Sim City we have cities Scylla you
say City skylines that's another shitty
answer but that last Sim City was rough
yeah I remember getting that day one
very very sad about it well anyway I
guess I'll move on Kelly do want to read
the next one sure I love the way this is
intro'd shalom after dark and solitude
crew as a 36 year old gamer dad I
thought the coronavirus quarantine is
the best time to start playing video
games with my three and a half year old
son
so I've handed him a ps4 controller not
the 500 million edition of course that's
mine and launched Lego Marvel Super
Heroes beside the tantrum sessions when
I tell him we need to close the game
we're having a great time together I
know some of you boys and girls grew up
to gamer parents and I wanted to know
what it's like any pros/cons sad happy
moments and stories you like to share
keep up the great work and stay safe
that's from Lyra Nora life
leerin from israel PS the chemistry
between you is something to envy at
thank you so much your letter yeah thank
you for writing in I played games with
my dad he had he bought a new PC to play
a very specific addition of worms when
it came out we would play tomb raider
quake but my like actually he was very
like he would play double-oh-seven night
fire with me and we'd play Gran Turismo
and stuff together but at the same time
we'd have a great we'd have a great time
but I do have a flashbulb memory of him
making me cry because we were playing a
golf 95 and I was so [ __ ] at it I did
not I couldn't get the timing down to
hit the swing and he made me cry the
pros and cons of a game a parent I was
gonna say like my parents pretty much
had no interest in video games until my
dad found out that they made video games
based on World War two and then Medal of
Honor became like a very big thing for a
while like I remember like one day he
went bought all of the metal on Medal of
Honor games he could get on Xbox and
then I remember the main reason I sold
him on the 360 was I was like Call of
Duty 2 day one you should take a look at
this and we played a bunch of like
split-screen and stuff with other
friends and like that I'd say like
playing World War 2 games was like what
did the trick but before that my parents
were like is gonna rot your brain
I've got no interestingness well we'll
get them for you so you can I don't know
talk about them with your friends on the
playground or whatever but other than
that they were not interested both of my
parents played video games my mom would
talk about playing like arcade games the
bowling alley growing up and stuff and
my mom my mom and dad have very
different gaming tastes I would say so
like my dad is really just into shooters
like that's his number one thing he's
been playing shooters as long as I can
remember
call of duty correspondent our college
correspondent Rick and he you know
showed me like doom and quake I remember
he had this mod for quake that put
Simpsons characters into the game on our
old like our gateway desktop in the
computer room oh yeah we used to call
that the computer room - yeah it was
technically I think his office but
seeing the point we'd cool it is study
mmm yeah yeah kind of the yeah the same
room my mom was really into Galaga which
is where I get my love of that game from
she bought herself a Gameboy Advance SP
to specifically play Namco arcade Museum
and then she borrowed my brother's DS to
play brain age just because of the
Sudoku but my mom also was really into
platformer so we played banjo kazooie
together but my mom has never been into
the violent stuff really and one of my
favorite like it was it's such at the
time but one of my favorite memories is
my dad got gta3 and me and my brother
who's four years younger than me so he
was really young at the time we were all
playing the ps2 was in my parents room
and I had the Gamecube in my room so we
were all in my parents room playing and
my mom found out that there were
prostitutes in the game and stuff so she
took away gta3 not just from me and my
brother but also from my dad and I found
that copy of gta3 when my parents were
moving and that was just like oh yeah
this was the troublemaker game my
parents never really were in a games but
my dad was always really into like
having like the coolest new hardware so
he would always be really into like
buying like the newest computer with
like the best graphics card and so he
would always be like
interested in games from a technical
standpoint so you'd be like oh I heard
this game has like the best graphics and
like you should get it and play it he
like come over so I'd be like hey Dad
come check this new game out i guy
like look how good it looks and he would
always like be excited to just like see
how visually good games would look which
is kind of interesting like he bought a
PlayStation 3 just for the blu-ray
player but I came home that's what my
dad did I came home one day cuz like I
never owned a console as a kid it was
like piscine and I had a gameboy and
then like finally around like 2006 I
like bought I own Xbox 360 and then like
I was like yep this will be my one
console and then like yeah well it
must've been like a couple months later
or whatever when the ps3 came out like I
just came home one day my dad just had a
ps3 there and he's like I bought a ps3 I
wanted the blu-ray player but here you
go you can play some games now it's like
okay but one memory I do have her
playing games is my mom is like the huge
Star Wars fan it's like her favorite
thing of all time so I I played like she
named you after John Luke Picard so
that's a little confused well she also
loves Star Trek as well and I also think
there aren't any good good like you know
her like way of like doubling up or
something like han dukes
[Laughter]
but I ended up playing Knights silver
republic with her it's like a like years
later after it came out I was just like
hey mom do you want to like play this
game cuz like you know I think it's like
it's such a good Star Wars story and she
was like yeah I want to try it so like I
actually had her play and I like walked
her through how to play it and like
that's a really really fond memory I
have did she love it she did she really
really liked it yeah that's so sweet
yeah very wholesome
and all right wait I have a really
crappy point go ahead I told my mom
likes platformers and puzzle games I
told my mom about candy crush right she
doesn't spend some money on candy crush
I was in college my dad called me and
was like what the [ __ ] have you done
and uh my mom's counter point to that
was you buy a new call of duty every
year that's $60 why can't I spend money
on candy crush and he was like fair
point and then it never came up again
oh god him though she really did alright
last question comes from Triceratops
from the discord this is kind of similar
to what we answered before but is there
a game you would love to wish into
existence it can be anything at all like
a canceled game a remake of a game or
even a game of your own imagination I
would like to wish a new Final Fantasy
main series game but it returns to the
NES roots both combat and graphically so
I guess the only caveat would be don't
pick a dead franchise or something like
that since we already kind of answered
that like I can't say Splinter Cell as
much as I want to say Splinter Cell I
know mine already all right go for it um
I want a GTA style game but you play as
the sex worker that's what I want I hope
I've talked about this pitch oh you have
I've had this pitch I play that that's
I'm gonna keep repeating it until it
happens it's what I want I also want my
Hideo Kojima dating sim where you play
as the Deo Kojima and you pick from a
suite of boys where's that I know
they're all real people which is why
that doesn't work but still Hideo
Kojima's best friends Emilia I'd exactly
- oh my game I she was silent hill's so
mm-hmm
but I feel like that's an easy one just
because PT was but it's when we have to
talk about
Oh
my game is in so in Yakuza 5 there's a
whole arc of that game where you play as
a character who is a upcoming idol and
the whole so instead of like combat
everything in the game is like rhythm
minigames and it's like you have like
street battles where you like dance offs
and you have like minigames or you're
doing like signings and stuff like that
so I would want a that expanded to a
full game where you play as Hatsune Miku
and you're like wandering around like a
virtue like you're like virtual Hatsune
Miku who like somehow has the ability to
walk around and you have to like live
the life of Hatsune Miku and and do
concerts and signings and I don't know
something happens and maybe maybe you
end up fighting people I don't know that
would kill Michael that would yeah I
speaking of Yakuza though I also just
want to put it out there that I would
love a standalone cabaret club game oh
yeah I'm a mobile game yeah just like a
mobile game where a man is the cavalry
yeah I'd pay real money for that yeah
man I don't know I'm thinking but I
can't think of anything about that that
halo game you and you came up with in
your dream yeah that's true my my halo
breath of the Wyatts sort of style game
which I think will be pretty cool and in
VR but it didn't have to be in VR that's
the game I want Jake I feel like you
don't have an answer because Neil
druckmann made a game based on your
brain that's true and I was about to say
why but I think you'll find out if you
listen to the spoiler kiss if you listen
the spoiler yes and when you guys play
it I'm sure you'd be like yeah I'll drop
a note and yeah when I when I experience
it I'm gonna be playing this weekend but
like yeah as I was playing that game I
learn the text in Cali and I was like I
think Neil druckmann is inside of my
head somehow because he made two
creative decisions that I would have
definitely made I probably wouldn't have
done it nearly as well as he did but I
was
like yeah if I made a game I would
definitely have both of these things in
it and they're very specific like
probably I doubt there are many people
who play this game who would like
probably be like oh yeah those two
things are what I want in a game I'm
gonna I'm gonna message you cuz I think
I know what one it is I think I saw Greg
playing this moment I will message you
and see if I got it right all right I
think that's it though that's it for
episode 46
thank you all so much for tuning in to
GameSpot after dark each and every week
we're gonna keep going we're gonna
rotate the cast a little bit see how
that goes we've got some more guests
planned
- I think next week we're gonna try to
have Jeff Bakalar on which should be fun
I haven't talked to him yet but
apparently two more has so if it doesn't
show up next week then it's long time
it's at am goof anyway Lucy what are you
working on where can people find you
I've been doing a bunch of play for all
streams been working on that with Tom
and chastity booking six weeks worth of
guests next week once look out for
Thursday unannounced but it's gonna be
very big we'll be promoting that from
Monday and we have the last podcast on
the left guys
which I'm very excited about we have we
were streaming Dark Souls with Marcus
Parks the other day so much fun so Henry
is going to be joining with Marcus and
we're gonna do some like what's the game
um it's like an FMV game and you have to
guess if people are lying and solve a
crime so very excited to put that to the
test
it's called like confusion okcousin
contraception contradiction
contradiction
contraception the game we're playing
that with them next week please tune in
very good donate for black lives matter
as well as Direct Relief and I'm on
Twitter at Lucy James games Callie how
about you I'm gonna be on one of the
play for all charity streams on well
today Friday yeah if you are listening
right when this episode goes up it'll be
a little bit later so check that
and then I like I said I'm working on
the isle of armour review and then I've
also put up the review for the last was
part two that contains spoilers I would
not suggest even clicking on it if you
don't want to be spoiled because I
mentioned a spoilery thing very very
close to the top of the page after the
spoiler warning so just to be extra
careful the thumbnail isn't gonna have
any spoilers or anything so don't worry
about that
and there Jake cut the spoiler free
video review which you can watch and
then Evan handled the spoilery video
review totally unprecedented thing that
we're trying for this just because this
game kind of horns it so yeah it's
juggling a lot and y'all nuclear are you
not too much I'm mostly just doing
behind-the-scenes stuff for play for all
both recording interviews and helping
out hey on the tech side I think I'm
gonna try and take some weight off his
shoulders hopefully soon I think that
that man is getting very very exhausted
he's been putting in so much work so
huge shout out to today he doesn't get
enough enough love for how much he does
behind the scenes on the text out of
that but otherwise I'm sure in the
coming weeks I'll be working on some
stuff and then for me we are I'm doing
Last of Us stuff there's gonna be a
couple last of his videos that'll go up
on embargo and throughout the next
couple days including the spoiler chat
so there'll be plenty of Last of Us to
stuff going up on site that you want to
check out and then the other thing John
look you're actually part of this too is
I think I can talk about this is we're
gonna have the creative I guess lead on
skype live Ian that Big Sky Ramon is
gonna be on for a stream with us and
we're gonna check that out which is
super exciting for those who don't know
it's basically a team trying to recreate
oblivion and Skyrim is engine and what
they've done so far is super impressive
so I think that'll be fun make sure to
check that out if you can that's Tuesday
9 a.m. PT right yep yep Tuesday 9 a.m.
if all things go plan we're gonna do a
technical test this
weekend or early next so you can't see
but anyway that's it thank you all so
much for tuning in and we'll see you
next week
[Music]